hello everyone and welcome back to a
special masked edition of the road 2000.
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
we're coming to you live
from st louis missouri where a new mask
mandate has just come into effect so you
may never see my face again
but i am still here to deliver the
highest quality chess content
available in the room uh ben feingold
joke
for the youtube viewers um but tonight i
want to talk about something really
exciting uh
one of my favorite tournaments in the
yearly cycle
is going on at the moment and that of
course is the fide world cup
so most chess tournaments tend to be
either round robins
or the open ones are swiss tournaments
with the swiss style pairings
but the world cup is a little bit unique
because it is a knockout tournament
so players are seated into a bracket
they play
two game matches with their opponent if
you lose your match you're
out of the events if you win you
continue on
and i find the formats be really
interesting because you get some
mismatches
and of course you get some surprises and
some upsets
so tonight i wanted to talk about um
some surprising games
and some some upsets that actually
occurred uh
in the event and hello hello welcome
thanks for joining so to start with i
want to talk about
the only americans still surviving in
the event and that is
uh 2018 u.s champion sam shankland
and he actually managed to defeat uh
famous russian player peter svidler
everybody's favorite
so we're going to take a look at this
game and it might not be all that
surprising anymore to see sam shanklin
beating guys
like peter svidler now four years ago uh
sam i think was trudging through the
2650s which is where a lot of these top
grand masters get stuck with their
rating on their their ascent to
to the top but sam has had a great uh
past three years to be honest he got
over 2700 and he's
proving that he belongs there so let's
take a look at this game against
peter here we start with d4 knight f6
c4 and of course g6 so
peter svidler is a pretty famous
grunfeld player
and so if white were to continue with
the normal knight to c3
trying to finally contest black for
control over the center
black of course is going to try to play
the move d5 to get the grunfeld you can
also play d6
bishop g7 to play um a king's indian
defense
but peter svidler very famous all he
does is play the grunfeld all day long
and has a great time so anticipating
this
sam shankland does something that's
maybe 20 years ago
would have been seen as outrageous but
these days happens every other game
which is
just the move h4 um so
some people like to credit uh alpha zero
and these new engines for coming up with
this idea
obviously the idea has existed uh a long
long time
chess is an old game and new ideas are
scarce
but doing it early on is becoming a
little bit more fashionable
so what's the point of this uh this move
pawn to h4 what is white trying to do
yeah ken
take advantage of the uh yeah
exactly uh white's uh sort of playing
this in response to the pawn
appearing on g6 he's anticipating that
svidler is gonna fianchetto with bishop
g7
likely want to castle king's side and
he's sort of preemptively
starting his attack on this side of the
board later on
and this pawn might advance further to
h5 and open up the h file or to h6
and challenge the bishop on g7 but for
now it's also a very useful piece
in cementing white's control over the g5
square
now the more traditional chess players
will say you know why
why do this now you should develop your
pieces first and then start doing things
like this
but these days you know it's never too
early to push your h pawn
uh so spidler just continues like normal
develops with bishop g7
we get knight c3 finally to prepare for
e4
and now rather than go for the more
traditional grunfeld with d5
with the inclusion of this pawn on h4
svidler actually
felt that d6 would be a better way to
continue allowing white to sort of take
over the center
so why not play d5 well i think d5 is is
still perfectly playable
but this is uh sort of the point of
sam's opening prep after d5
he's gonna go for the immediate h5 and
take advantage of the fact
this knight is slightly overworked i
can't both defend the pawn on d5
and capture this pawn on h5 of course
we're not super interested
in fracturing our pawns like this and if
we
sort of ignore this pawn well then
white's going to open up this h
file and have a a ready-made attack so
sam's opening prep has sort of been
specially designed
against fiddler here saying yeah i know
you're the big grunfeld guy
but i'm not even letting your pawn get
to d5 so
why play h4 so early i think it's for
this specific purpose basically we
wanted to stop black playing d5
and we can do so by overworking this
knight
sitting on f6 so for all those reasons
swiddler chooses this move d6
and white is able to take over the
center with e4
now these positions i always find to be
very very interesting
with black so there are a few different
ways
black can treat this pawn trio in the
center of the board
so who who knows some common ideas for
black to
sort of attack these pawns
and not necessarily attack these pawns
but just get any kind of claim
in the center
yes so pushing the c pawn is common in
these positions
and you get more benoni style structures
where we're leaving this diagonal open
and white is probably pushing forward to
d5 in many cases
and we get this attack on on the dark
squares
also you can push the e pawn and try to
get the more
classical king's indian style of
structures where you're leaving the c
pawn back on c7 and you are potentially
trying to push over here on the king's
side
and there's actually sort of a
combination
of ideas that that black can go for as
well that's not
related to uh going for a structure
and so sorry that was a little bit
confusing so let me rephrase
we don't necessarily have to go c5 or e5
right away
there's sort of another way we can uh
force white's hand
in the center so other ideas besides
these two
structural approaches c65
so c6 d5 is is another way to play
but uh here
probably you know i think you would
agree the normal plans would make more
sense than c65
so black can interject something before
challenging these uh
this d4 pawn with another pawn and it's
gonna make his position a lot more uh
a lot more active right away rather than
the closed positions where we
play our plans this one is going to be a
bit more open
and tactical
any ideas
so part of it's related to this move h4
white has
spent some time over here and it's going
to give black an extra opportunity
in the center
all right let's turn to the youtube chat
and prof l
axis has an idea uh and that idea is
knight to c6
so this is the move i was trying to fish
for my hints were not really
uh at the top of their game tonight but
the idea
is that um we are developing this knight
before challenging the pawn
with with e5 now what's the purpose of
this
well we want to uh you know of course
develop our knight to an active square
we're actually just looking to cement
this knight onto the d4
square before white is is ready to
handle it
now if you can imagine we had this
position with the pawn on h2
and the knight on f3 this move would be
a lot less advisable
because then white would just play d5
this knight would not really have any
squares to go to
because white would be covering those
squares but since white has spent some
time on h4
knight c6 becomes a lot more reasonable
to try to attempt
so how should sam respond to knight to
c6
what do we think you know black is
trying to go e5
and cement this knight onto d4 what's
going to be our uh
our game plan against this
okay what does that mean
which which pawns what are we talking
here ken i don't like
yeah so we actually can't advance the e
pawn because
uh it's just defended too many times and
again the queen trade is not gonna
necessarily be in our favor but i think
you're saying push d5
right yeah so yeah you can definitely
try to push d5
but i think black's idea here is that
this is a lot preferable than if you
play d5
after i commit to either c5 or e5 black
is going to have a lot more opportunity
now
and a lot more flexibility as well for
example if we jump into e5
you might be attempting to play uh pawn
to f4
but you're leaving a lot of squares
behind right i'm going to be occupying
these squares
you've made a lot of weaknesses and i
can either play c6
or e6 sort of at any time i want to to
challenge your center
so what was that or e5 yeah especially
okay after e4
then e5 becomes a lot more a lot more
reasonable
f4 is a bit much though let's say even
bishop e2
then uh black king castle black can play
something like
something like c6 and start challenging
this pawn on d5 in a variety of ways
so this is fiddler's idea um but
if we analyze the position a little bit
more concretely
you might realize that black doesn't
necessarily have
uh have the resources to keep a knight
on d4 and so this is sam's idea he's
just going to challenge the d4
square um before moving the d-pawn
and sort of meet peter's fiddler head-on
so how can we maintain control over this
square
yeah just knight ge2 so of course we're
not jumping to f3
this would play into black's hands
pretty heavily with this move bishop f3
uh taking away our dark squared defender
and we're not playing bishop
e3 either because knight g4 again would
be
sort of playing into black's hand so
that just leaves one more option
knight ge2 uh to defend the square and
we can meet bishop g4
with f3 just pushing the black bishop
back
and svidler um has now committed to this
knight c6 idea uh knight ge2 comes on
the board
but that doesn't mean we have to abandon
it all together so spoiler plays e5
anyways
no i'm sorry so they're castles we get
f3 and then e5 anyways
um inserting those two moves
so e5 anyways this is the move that
white has been waiting for
to commit to playing d5 in the center so
that's what we get now and
now of course swiddler backs up with
knight to e7
or just plays knight d4 anyways uh
and this is what's going to sort of
crack the game wide open whenever
black goes for this knight c6 knight d4
idea
first of all if this knight just is
allowed to stand on d4 black tends to
just be better
so in general usually this knight gets
captured one way or another
and then we're gonna see diagonals open
we're gonna see the d5 square open
and the game is is going to be uh
happening very very rapidly it's going
to be an open position
with with a lot going on so knight d4
played in in the position and bishop e3
by sam shanklin
so of course if you were to just capture
twice
uh what's going on in in this position
here
why why not just take the free pawn
well it's it's potential but unless
there's a good one
then what's the big deal
yeah specific is the one i'm looking for
so there's there is
actually a good discovery here
so net h5 i just move my queen right
i'll say queen back to f2 guarding your
threat
i don't know
well d5 i take your knight
e4 i take your knight
sometimes
okay the chat room has it for you this
time so the tactical idea is still
knight takes e4 so you're on the right
track
uh threats and captures and of course
now
we we can take back with one of the
pieces because our queen hangs
and queen e4 is met by rookie 8.
so for the moment we we can't take this
knight on d4
but you know sam's not really panicking
because after bishop e3
it seems like black is just unable to to
maintain this piece
on the uh on the d4 square so
what should uh sphidler do about it or
do you have a question yeah are you
surprised
that he went for like the structure as
far as
the structure is black because i would
think that h4 is not really useful in
the dna structures
right going forward
yeah um so back to this knight c6
decision it is
uh really interesting right that he went
for knight c6 and i imagine
he he has just analyzed this h4 line
concretely and thought that knight c6
was solving his problems
but uh julian in in the live audience
which
i don't know if you've attended many
lectures recently making your youtube
return
but um but
julian was saying you know we the whole
game is
the whole opening is pretty much about
this move h4
you know this is going to influence
black's decision making pretty heavily
so the question was why go for this
knight c6 idea
rather than the binoni structure which
if we just put some moves on the board
let's say castles bishop e2
and let's just say we get a normal
bononi
uh isn't this move sort of sticking out
like a sore thumb now like why why is
your pawn on h4
you would much rather have this pawn on
h3 to guard the g4 square
right um and i don't know
the answer to this question um but
i do think that knight c6 does make some
concrete sense as well
right if if you can make this knight d4
idea work
then white's opening is is kind of
refuted like
your opening idea is just bad if i'm
able to play this knight d4 line
and and make it work but the bad news
for fiddler is i think sam's prep was
was a little bit better than his in in
this particular instance
yeah knight knight ge2 and then um well
i i imagine they both had seen that far
before the game
but uh but what follows
does become very very interesting so
yeah in general this is a good point
though um you want to analyze
the sort of the the difference in your
openings like if your opponent plays one
really strange move or an idea you're
not familiar with
it's important to look at the
differences and look at your options and
say
well i know in these positions this pawn
might not work
work quite as well as in some other
positions but i haven't done the work to
tell you
why c5 isn't what peter's fiddly did
but okay knight c6 in the game and we
get our game position with bishop e3
so if you're familiar with these
positions there's really only one choice
here for black
you're never taking on e2 because you've
wasted
three tempe to develop one of white's
pieces not ideal
so you have to commit to having this
knight on d4 moving this knight does
nothing it's still attacked too many
times
so you have to go pawn to c5 here um
and so as white of course we're also
sort of committed to challenging this
knight on d4
again if this knight is allowed to stand
here black is just going to be better
so we get d take c6 you have to remove
this defender of the knight
and now's with this point is not to play
knight takes c6
just accepting kind of a bad position
where you don't control d4
you don't control d5 and you have
weakness on d6
but b takes c6 and the idea is that he
is just
gambiting upon here this time there's no
trick
because there's no big discoveries so
sam does go ahead and capture the pawn
and the question is now uh what what's
the point why does fiddler give up his
his e pawn here well he does get a lot
in return for it number one his king's
castled white's king is on e1
number two this bishop is going to be a
very very powerful piece
on the open diagonal and just
stylistically at least
i think this is more in line with the
types of positions uh peter spidler is
playing where
it's it's it's all about this bishop
right the gruenfeld players they
they can't get enough um
but okay we we need to change these
general ideas
of uh compensation in into a concrete
series of moves so how are we justifying
this pawn sacrifice what is black gonna
do
to turn this one pawn down deficit
into uh either an attack or a plan
or a way to activate
any ideas
yeah and and that's exactly where your
focus should be
um in many many openings where you
fiancado your bishop the focus is very
often on making sure this bishop is as
powerful as possible
and so that's going to be our line of
thinking we want to use this powerful
bishop
to create problems for white and the
question
the question then is how drive the
bishop off of d4
yes so c5 is going to be an important
idea for us i
don't remember if svidler does it
immediately but c5 is going to be
important to drive the bishop away
what other moves should should be coming
to mind
queen to b6 uh okay maybe after c5 queen
to b6
there's actually a better square for the
queen though a better square than b6
even after
you know it's it's not not uh not
attacked
and ken noticed where my mouse cursor
was sitting it's on the af5 square
so yeah queen a5 and this is a pretty
classic way to apply some pressure on
the queen's side
uh one more piece we can bring into the
game the rook coming to b8
and this is pretty classic compensation
you know who's to say if it's
enough that's going to be up to you know
the hours of computer prep that both
players did
but you can see black's idea right you
have this powerful dark squared bishop
you can bring your pieces in
very very quickly to attack and uh
on the surface level it looks as if um
black black's idea might be good here so
it's really interesting to see how sam
treats this though
so we start with actually rook v8 by
peter sidler
um white goes queen c2 just to help
defend these dark squares
and now we do get c5 uh ken's move
we're gonna drop the bishop back to f2
and here
black goes bishop to e6
so uh at low depths the computer thinks
bishop e6 is like a big mistake or
something
but uh they they usually end up near
near the same position
uh the deeper you go at least from what
i've found i haven't done super super
deep analysis of this one um but bishop
b6
and so the question now you know we've
been thinking from svidler's perspective
for for a while here because his play
has been a little bit harder to decipher
white's play has been pretty simple
we get rid of the knight on d4 we take
the extra pawn but now it's time for
white to make some
decisions so where are we putting our
king and how are we developing our
pieces
so instead of rook b8 and c5 why was d5
not played
um
okay maybe i can take and go e5
knight d7 oh boy
we're really uh testing me here yeah i
mean i mean f4
and then you're pushing through so let's
take a look so
there are a few things you have to have
to calculate here c takes i think is
automatic
and then um yeah the question is can i
get away with this
can i get away with this and uh i'm not
sure which one i
actually like like better
h5 but then i'm thinking um
it might be as simple as
uh queen d2 rookie 8 and queen side
castles
and your d-pawn should be falling right
yeah yeah so d5 definitely is
is one line of thinking but i feel like
um i feel like this is more in the wrong
direction
um so the idea of c5 is for this
more long-term compensation with
attacking on these dark squares d5 is a
more immediate
plan right d5 is saying your king's in
the center i'm going to blow it up
and and win a win in the center of the
board
but uh yeah so
d5 is is more just raw calculation i
guess
but let's stick with the game so rick b8
c5 bishop f2
and bishop e6 uh so just challenging
the queen side even further sort of
trying to bait white into playing
something
silly like like b3 at a later date we're
pressuring c4
not because we really care about the
light squares but because we care about
white weakening the dark squares further
oh so that's why you don't do v3 because
then the dark square bishop's even
stronger
oh absolutely especially with with the
rook on a1 this is just kind of a
kind of kind of a kind of a monster here
and again queen a5 is going to be coming
in
and you've got some problems so
that that's the question now for white
is black has made his intentions very
clear
black is going to be developing to the
queen slide challenging all of your dark
squares
and the question now is you know you're
up a pawn how do you
develop and keep your kings safe
and that vague question uh provokes a
much simpler question which is
this way or this way
don't like either one that's fair that's
fair
left or right chat left or right
prophylaxis says not queenside tim
fisher says kingside
everybody seems to agree
well the bad news is this is illegal but
uh you can play bishop e2 or bishop d3
and follow that up with with king side
castles i guess
all right ken's gonna go queen slide why
do you say queen side ken i
like that backward corner with d6 you
like that backward pawn on d6 so you're
doing it for the tempo the tempo on the
pawn you want this rook on the d
file you want the rook off of the a file
okay
does anybody in the live audience think
we should go the other way
crickets okay um so
i tend to agree that the the king should
be put onto the queen side in this case
for
for a lot of reasons um namely it's
it's sort of just awkward to to get to
the king's side here
um black has a couple of different ideas
the knight might go this way the knight
might go this way
but let's say you know just knight d7
and we do get to castle king's side
now all of a sudden our move h4 first of
all
doesn't make much sense anymore uh when
you play a move like h4 it's because
your rook is supporting it
pushing this pawn forward is going to
open the h file or you'll get upon an h6
as a nice pawn wedge and without the
rook on h1 these ideas make a little bit
less sense
and beyond that you know it sort of
doesn't really matter
if our king is on the queen side if
black breaks through on the queen side
black's plan is kind of working i mean
maybe you don't lose the game right away
you don't get checkmated right away
but if black is able to break through
over here you've still got a lot of
problems
so sam's idea i think is to
just castle queenside you know if black
breaks through over here you're still
going to have a lot of problems
but at least in this case number one
your king can actually act as a little
bit of a defender
and number two you're not really giving
up on this kingside initiative
you know you have your counter play on
the king's side you have your counter
play
down the d file and
even though it seems scary to put your
king on the side of the board where your
opponent is attacking
in this case i think it's very worth it
number one for the tempo
number two because it's not giving up on
this this kingside kingside attack
um okay so i think queenside castles is
is the move order in the game
and we get knight d7 by svidler
and this is actually a move i i think
i'm a little bit uh
a little bit critical of i think this
night would have been better served
going
going this way and we'll see why in the
game but let's stick with the game for
now
um bishop c5 i think we uh
keep it up for the bishop no yeah i uh
i i actually didn't even uh i missed
this simple tactic
when i was analyzing but it doesn't work
for some reason because i think the
computer also missed this tactic
um which means it doesn't work but
let's go ahead and try to figure it out
here and maybe we'll just cheat if i
can't figure it out because
this looks pretty good right this looks
pretty good everybody
yeah queen a5 bishop d6
i don't know i don't know about that one
um all right let's just cheat let's just
cheat cheating's fun everybody
knight h5 and
okay now bishop 65 is is just good it's
just good
okay i see so
um i apologize i think uh back here
instead of bishop e6
this is a moment when we we could have
gone knight h5
and something like queen a5 um and
i think this would have been would have
been a better plan than than what peter
went for in the game
but uh my mistake in the game after
bishop v6 actually is played and we get
to this position
knight h5 is actually impossible because
i imagine this is just very very good
computer wanted to like kick the knight
first and then do this
but uh it it's all the same
um okay so not knight h5 there good
catch but i do think
uh knight h5 here and queen a5 would
have been a better way to go about it
and the reason for that
is going to be what we what we see in
the game i think white is able to get a
pretty nice
nice idea through so bishop b6 queen
side castles knight d7
and rook takes d6 so sam just says
you've undefended your pawn on the d6
square i'm gonna capture that too
um okay but you know peter has has his
idea there's no reason to change now
we get queen a5 again pressure on the
dark squares
is the name of the game for black here
but now the question is
with white you know we we're now up two
full pawns
but that's becoming less and less
relevant as as the game continues here
so how do we keep uh keep activating our
pieces
as white
and this one isn't anything mind blowing
it's very logical
with how white is played thus far
we need to
yeah um we don't really want to shift
our focus to this d
file um because black is vacating this d
file very very quickly black is going to
come here and
continue making threats or or even to b6
maybe
and that bishop is keeping the roof yeah
yeah um
oh yeah nothing matters rook b2 who
cares um
well okay so it did matter so
bishop e1 julian spots all the tactics
uh rook b2
is is gonna be
either good or not good i suspect good
um
if you take with the king you're gonna
get checked so let's say
queen takes bishop takes and
it gets slightly scary slightly scary
over here definitely not
not the most comfortable position queen
a3 might be a bad move though
probably uh like b8 maybe 95
and some kind of attack is coming so
sam inserts this move bishop e1 um
number one it just defends the knight so
those ideas no longer work
number two you know discovery ideas are
definitely going to be
in the position once again so knight e5
for peter svidler and now
the idea that i was talking about um f4
of course
comes into play all right miss
remembering everything
um let me tell you this is so much
easier when i'm in the studio and i can
just have the notation in front of me
now if i have the notation in front of
me they'll cheat and read it it's
ridiculous
um but okay
so 95 and yeah this is actually a point
i wanted to mention so 95
attacks this this pawn on c4 i sort of
hinted earlier
that b3 is never really going to be um
not not it's never really going to be a
move that white wants to play
um the engine thinks b3 is is kind of
playable
i gives white some tiny edge
um but then you know the deeper you go
the less it it seems to matter
that uh you defended your your c4 pawn
now why didn't sam go for it in the game
well number one it's intuitively just
kind of hard to play i think
um and number two you're almost
immediately losing the pawn
uh with queen a3 stuff anyways um i
think it's bad for black to do this
immediately
but just for example like uh
this this pawn is is not long for this
world in many variations anyways
again i don't think that's the line
black should go for but that line isn't
isn't really going away um how would
play continue here
i think simply rook d8 takes takes
and now black has the d file and again
pressure here and pressure pressure on
the queen side
um so instead of b3 sam plays f4 sort of
forcing
uh black's hand to take on uh c4
we're going to take this knight with our
light squared bishop because we care
about our dark squares
and we don't care about our light
squares um bishop takes
on uh on c4 and now
e5 is is very natural we want to shut
off the bishop
so white has successfully sort of
defended these dark squares on the queen
side
by shutting down this bishop with this
idea of e5 of course
that didn't happen for free black won
this pawn on c4 and now of course
after rook d8 take take h5
the pawn on a2 is is going to be falling
as well
and so up to this point this has been a
very very interesting game
um the the computer evaluation has
changed a couple times it was never
really in black's favor but it was
you know between zeros and plus one
basically back and forth it couldn't
really make up its mind on what was
going on it was like yeah you're all
idiots this line was better
but then you follow this line and it
doesn't really doesn't really make sense
from from what i could see um and at
this point
the computer is like yeah okay you guys
did did good enough
chess is a draw um you have this back
and forth
where you know white is up material and
black has this pressure
then white gives back some of these
pawns to shut out this bishop
uh but you know white is attacking on
the king's side still
black is attacking on the queen side
still and so it turns out
neither player has messed up bad enough
to uh
to be much worse here and then
after h takes g6 h takes g6
uh we get this move knight e4 hitting
this queen
and then black blunders
big blunder here so black to move
where does this queen belong where
should this queen go
that's the question you're a [ __ ] if
you don't see that one of the queen
moves is a blunder
the chat room just instantly knows the
correct move
it's crazy no no they've got the right
one
unless they're saying that that one's
the blunder in which case they're wrong
because that one's that one's good
could be
a genius
so uh keeping in line with black's
previous play uh two moves should be
sort of your candidates right we we want
to keep up our pressure on the dark
squares
we want to keep up our attack and really
okay three moves should be your
candidate so
queen b5 or queen b6 trying to go rook
b8
to to kind of attack here a little bit
more or queen a6
trying to keep sort of your your ideas
alive on the a
file um i guess you could consider queen
c7 but to me this one
it's not like a big blunder or anything
i don't think at least but
it seems the least relevant of the boobs
your queen's not
not really participating there um so
which of these three moves is the big
blunder
which of these three moves is the big
blunder
yes brian's the genius queen b6 played
in the game
now the hard question why
what's wrong with putting the queen on
b6 it's obviously gonna be attacked
um obviously
brian with the joke answer is
surprisingly close to the truth but i'll
give you a little bit
a little bit longer to actually think
this one
is bad is through later twice gonna play
bishop h4 and mission takes d8 is on the
queen and if it were somewhere else then
it wouldn't be
not quite not quite
ah and caesar martin in the chat room
has the obvious idea of course
of course you need the the queen on one
of these two squares
why do you need the queen on one of
these two squares because you're playing
rook c4
you guys didn't see rook c4 what are we
doing here guys
all right obviously i'm being sarcastic
um
but it does turn out there is one very
relevant variation where you need the
queen to be defending the rook
on c4 in order for uh
for your ideas to work so let's see what
happens in the game
okay so first of all we get bishop h4
only winning move
attacking the rook on d8 and so you
would think
you know why not play rook d4
super genius move i'm gonna go rook c4 i
am going to pin your queen to your king
and you're going to be so sad so
so sad um so what is the stunning
winning idea for white in this position
yeah that's what brian said you guys
didn't listen to brian
um let me see what julian said yeah
so uh of course brian in the live
audience i don't think i i repeated it
for the the stream so i don't know if
they heard but he had the exact right
idea
the queen on b6 is misplaced because
after knight f6 king f8 knight d7
you're forked um so the
the stunning move here is is knight f6
which uh
on the surface doesn't really seem super
impressive why don't we just take it
and pin the queen well because i'm not
taking this with the pawn i'm taking
this with my bishop
and then i don't need the queen to
checkmate you this is uh this is the
nasty thing
and sacking isn't gonna be good enough
even though you win my queen back
uh rooks are worth more than bishops so
white would win
um so knight f6 is the start and then of
course the
the idea that was somewhat missed is
that after
king to f8 um knight d7 is
is coming with check and picking up your
queen very very sad
very very sad for uh
for black here um so what was played in
the game
uh yeah we get knight f6 king f8 and i'm
sorry so yeah now the idea is knight d7
check
is good enough to stop rook c4 so with
this
in mind what is white's follow-up here
to to keep the attack flowing
what's our next move
uh
so julian i think uh had mentioned this
line already but
do you have an idea in the back
okay it's all good
and then come back with the knight to g5
um
no we need our knight here to stop rook
c4
so if we try to reroute this knight then
we get we get pinned
so
that's also true that's also true um but
of course now that we've stopped rick c4
from being a good idea
sam's idea is to attack the rook because
now
rook c4 still isn't a good idea um so he
attacks the rook makes the rook move
away
and then of course if we step back to
some naive square
the bishop comes in and it's worse than
you thought you're not just losing a
queen here and you're not just losing a
queen you're
you're getting checkmated so sad uh no
chances
so what does fiddler come up with well
he takes this knight on f6
we are actually just gonna take back
with the pawn
um i haven't analyzed this in depth
because at this point everything loses
but i imagine this is also pretty good
for white it's just that it's a little
bit less convincing than the game
um it actually i mean maybe this isn't
very convincing at all actually
um no so yeah
we take on f6 first and and for those
ideas that queen c5 is coming so uh
if you don't take on f6 you also are
gonna have big problems for example
what's the idea if rook c4 checkmate
so you have to get rid of this pawn uh
then we can take on c5 with check rather
than take the rook
then after rook d6 who sees the final
two move combination to end the game two
moves is all you need
and uh and swidley throws in the towel
here
you've done the heavy lifting at this
point
bishop to h4 bishop h4 is one idea
brian queen c8 queen c8 and
what's your follow-up yeah that's right
so um bishop h4 it i mean it might win
but uh once you see the right idea it's
it's not really gonna okay queen d4
queen oh queen up four is check yeah
don't get checked ken check is bad
um but queen c8 check is good enough
and then uh i asked brian for a
follow-up he gave me the most relevant
one
king g7 is checkmate
um king e7 is actually going to be
bishop h4 now
with the the pin idea and
either piece queen d8 is rook h8
and even rook d8 is gonna be rook h8
here um and the unfortunate news
for uh for black is that there's no way
to
to save your pieces here so what happens
if
queen takes how do we win the queen
you check with the rogue i mean you take
the rook with the queen and then you
bring your dark square bishop in
yeah bishop d4 and you get skewed
check and you can't block because i will
still just take
maybe even with the queen to be mean and
uh you're gonna get checkmated and lose
the queen
so after rook h8 petersfield resigns and
sam shankland american hero
continues on to uh i believe the
quarterfinals this was his semi
or round of eight match
yeah uh turns out sam good author good
chess player too
who would have expected who would have
expected
um so actually of the games i wanted to
show tonight this was the least
of an upset sam is actually only
outraged by peter swidler by
five rating points which would have been
an absurd thing to say four years ago
but
sam his rating goes up smithers rating
yeah
it's over 2700 um
so uh any questions on this game this is
a pretty
complex game there are a lot of ideas
going on but
uh in the end both players were playing
very very well through the entire middle
game keeping the balance
with with you know black's pressure on
the queen's side white's extra material
and then white finding a way
to to change this uh imbalance
and then uh tactics that'll do it
yeah go ahead so um
i'm sorry so i did mean to uh to look at
these for a little bit so queen b5 what
happens if we try a similar idea
something like bishop h4
and knight f6 well the problem here of
course is that that after king f8 uh
where
we don't have our 97 ideas and i
i think white would actually be busted
close to busted if if white did still
try to kind of naively go for
go for these ideas we're gonna bishop f2
just rook c4 and it's
it's over um i'm sorry
so there was one more idea that i found
in my analysis
that i i forgot to show here and that's
bishop takes c5
so bishop takes c5 here is somewhat
interesting
but it's not enough to actually save the
game just
rook c5 and queen d7 if queen c5
then you got him you tricked him you
tricked them so hard
you lose your queen but uh again rooks
are worth more than bishops
but rook c5 is gonna be good enough and
and white is busted
so instead after queen b5 white has to
go for the slightly
uh milder move knight to d6
um we can go queen a6 we could have gone
queen e6 immediately
but black's actually not so unhappy
about driving this knight to d6 i
believe
and then white is still going to try to
activate on the side of the board
black is going to regroup the pieces a
little bit
and we're just going to end up in some
position you know black has
a strong bishop on e6 controlling a lot
of squares
white has a strong knight on d6 although
it can be uh can be
forced away black's gonna continue to
try to attack over here on the queen
side and
it's a chess game it's a chess game
uh okay anything else that we should
talk about with this game before we move
on we are running a little short on time
but uh we can power through it
all right then well well let's move
along so now
i want to talk about our grand master in
residence's least favorite person
uh today and that is velomir ivic
evitch i don't know um but
why is this our grandmaster in
residence's least favorite person
well velomir actually uh knocked out our
grand master robert hungaski
in round one of the world cup um but the
good news for robert
is that he went on to beat a bunch of uh
other really strong players
so he can use that as as a good excuse
so
i want to look at one of the more
shocking upsets
from early in the world cup which is
this guy
velimir ivic against vallejo ponce so of
course the spanish player
who's been over 2700 for quite some time
now
so i want to sort of zoom through the
opening here because we are a little bit
short on time
but we did have a french defense with
knight c3
black plays this move knight f6 which
people continue to do this
to this day and it seems like more and
more
black is getting bad positions out of
this opening um which happens to be the
case here
uh of course in this type of french
we're gonna it's gonna be distinct
from the advanced french because white
is essentially
you know pseudo winning a tempo uh
in the advance versus the advanced
french lines because we're making this
night move twice
that gives white a little bit more time
to get the quote-unquote ideal setup to
defend the dark squares correct me if
i'm wrong on any of this julian julian
a little bit more expensive a little bit
more experience in these e45 positions
than i am
not e4 e6 positions um
but yeah because we gain this time on
the night white is able to play this
move f4
we're gonna see white be able to sort of
regroup the pieces pretty favorably
to defend against black attacking our
center
g4 early anymore um depends on the line
it depends on the line ken sometimes
queen g4 but not gonna not gonna be the
case here we get knight f3
knight c6 bishop e3 and a6
by black is preparing some some queen
side stuff
also stopping some queen side stuff
knight back to e2 and again uh this is
the quote unquote ideal setup where all
of white's pieces are helping to defend
these dark squares in the center
uh queen b6 queen c1 even defends this
dark square
bishop e7 c3 and now
white has done such an excellent job of
defending this d4
square one two three four times that
black gives up and attacks the e5 square
instead which tends to be the case in
these openings
and now white does actually play a
really interesting idea
which is going to look familiar if you
watched the previous game
um very often in these positions
you'll get uh e takes f6
uh by whites sometimes it's a mistake if
black is able to recapture with the g
pawn and build a big center sometimes
it's it's just okay for both sides and
that that does seem to be the case
in these positions and there are a
number of games here where the center
gets blown up
and white puts a knight in the center
and you get this classic french
struggle where black is trying to play
e5 to get this bishop into the game
and white is sort of left without any
center pawns playing
against the center pawns with this
pieces um
instead of that though we get a
different idea by vlamir evitch
ivic which is once again
to uh to play this pawn h4 move and
yeah it just keeps showing up ken it
just keeps showing up
so what is the point of h4
in this position compared to the
previous position well we don't have
this pawn on g6 yet so it's
not quite the same as the previous idea
where sam was able to rip open the h
file
a little bit later on in this case we
have the pawn on
f6 and i believe velomir's idea is quite
simple he's going to play h4
h5 h6 and once this pawn moves out of
the way
he's going to have a lot of dark squared
weaknesses right this pawn on f6
is going to be a little bit tender and
just the dark squares in general
on the king side are going to be a
little bit weak and i wasn't kidding
when i said his idea it was
h4 h5h6 okay that was his idea
so we see it in the game and black plays
g6 of course
you want to keep this h file closed uh
lest you get mated in a horrible fashion
like peter svidler
um in the sunday class
to g7 yes so ken astutely pointing out
that in our sunday classes which are for
kids
um white would play h takes g7 x clam
uh removing the pawn from g6 and winning
in stunning fashion
yeah and why wouldn't you do it why
wouldn't you
um so after g6 now the game continues to
be interesting the question
is uh how do we manage
attacking on the king side like this uh
when you know the center is closed and
captioning
not
our king well available opponent is
actually making some threats here
right so we we did such a good job of
defending d4
it might be easy to forget about it but
this is kind of a relevant pin
in the position because we're not so
happy if we're taking back with the
piece
and then our center gets exploded on on
e5
so where what can we do with our king to
make it safe
what can we do
so if you guessed put it opposite the
rook on an open file
or soon to be open file you were correct
um so this is a more common idea than
you might expect in in these positions
uh once the f pawn moves with the center
closed especially with the center open
usually not a good idea but the center
is closed and white is
banking on keeping the center closed
right he's defending his dark squares
with all of his pieces
uh he doesn't want uh black to open
things up and so he goes king f2 he
steps out of this pin
the king should be relatively safe here
even after um
we get some some trades in the center
right you know the center is closed
this diagonal isn't really going to be
an issue and all of white's pieces are
sort of around
to to defend the king and it turns out
uh velmir had uh you know thought about
this
pretty correctly like as black how do
you continue the attack here
it seems really really difficult um
yeah okay i mean you sacked the exchange
you got rid of one of my pieces
defending my d4 square
i've got two others though he didn't do
that he didn't do that
um and you're nowhere nowhere near
attacking my king
so the the question is well okay why do
i have to attack the white king why
can't i i play on the queen side
and and the answer is you know how do
you play on the queen side you want to
play knight b6 to play knight c4
white plays white plays b3 and then
you know you want to play knight b4 or
something to to like checkmate or
to win my queen i'll defend my square
and go a3
and if your knight retreats like all of
a sudden
your queen might be getting trapped and
and things are getting very very scary
for
for black um and this is the problem in
the position for black
is you know you can't play on the king's
side
and your pieces are sort of stepping on
each other's toes on the queen's side
and so what do you do and
that is the question that vallejo ponds
was was not able to answer
it turns out this position is just very
very good for white already
black doesn't really have any ideas here
and has
to to kind of go for some desperation so
what should black have done instead well
the answer to that question
is probably not play this line of the
french
but i think a better response to that is
sort of in line with this move queen a5
i think this was the moment
where black sort of started going astray
instead i think black needs to
go back to you know preparing to play on
the queen side a little bit more
thoroughly
with starting again with pushing a rook
pawn and let's say we get something
similar
queen d2 a4 and
this case i think white is uh
smart to stop black from playing a3 and
then you play something like
like knight a5 and you start pressuring
some of these squares
your pieces are a lot more harmonious on
the queen side and yeah the king side is
still going to be a little bit scary for
black
but at least in this case you know what
black has counter play
on the queen's side instead
um we got none of those moves in queen
a5 and after this i think leopons was
sort of committed to a losing plan
but let's see what happens we get takes
takes takes takes
and then the move everybody saw coming
what does black do here
in his desperation to get some activity
yeah he just takes on e5 um so
white did such a good job of making sure
these pawns were
well defended but uh black is just gonna
sack a piece to get rid of them
yeah this isn't exactly an uncommon idea
in the french sometimes it's actually
very strong to rip open the center like
this
but in this case white just has way too
many defenders around the king
and even though you you do get both of
my center pawns
um this is just completely winning for
white uh king g1 is the simplest
stepping out of all of the checks and
then after knight g4
the bishop comes onto the strong dark
square diagonal
in tandem with the h pawn and things
just go downhill from here you know
white can offer queen trades now because
white has more pieces
black has to decline and then we just
activate here
take bishop d6 and then one last little
flourish by
velmir is going to put the game away um
how do we uh basically just
you know end the game here how do we end
the game
with white we have a nice little idea to
simplify
and win
one last puzzle for you before we wrap
up
julian yeah queen b3
played in the game and very surprisingly
this pawn on d5 is
simply indefensible um
yeah i mean this this pawn's in the
center of the board and it's attacked
one time
and you just can't add a defender of
course the bishop is overworked
so this doesn't work and you might be
thinking well wait a second isn't this
knight hanging
and you would be correct except for the
fact that i can take you back
and if you are so foolish as to play
knight takes e5
i will take on d5 with check attacking
two things at the same time
you know black strong chess player
defends both things at the same time
but then loses to uh to the idea of
checkmate
um
uh yeah well what if knight e5 then
ah okay well julian is is uh
you know uh less less romantic than uh
than uh velamir was in this game but
yeah i guess just queen d5 immediately
is gonna work too but in the game after
bishop takes e5 uh
black actually plays queen g5 um velimir
just retreats back to d4
get rook f7 queen g3 and the game didn't
last
uh too much longer after this we get
rick takes g4
and knight d5 to end the game
uh of course i think here is where
vallejo pons just resigns of course you
can't really move this rook
because of checkmate can't really take
this knight
because you lose all your pieces
bishop c4 and this is just going to be
game over
you know i'm gonna be so mean and check
meet you anyways
um and that is uh one of the
bigger upsets throughout the event and
with that i think i'm running just a
little bit over time
so as ben simon is putting in the
youtube chat be sure to hang around
we've got grand master in residence
robert hungaski here
uh also a victim of velomirs in the
world cup
and he's gonna talk about uh i think
some insane
end games for you guys so thank you as
always so much for joining me on the
road 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you